وانضم الينا منك يا مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل حذيفه انت تتواجد في احد المنازل
الاوكرانيه ااا حالهم حال مليون ونصف ربما
اكثر من الاوكرانيين الذين يعانون من
انقطاع الكهرباء
والشتاء البارد انقل لنا الصوره من عندك
يعني انخفاض درجات الحراره هنا في العاصمه
وفي جميع المدن الاوكرانيه بشكل عام طبعا
ازمه التي تحدثت عنها قبل قليل ايضا
تتفاخر تتحدث همم هو عمده المدينه قبل
قليل همم في التلفزيون الوطني الاوكراني
وتحدث عن هذه الازمه وقال انهم لن
يستطيعوا ان يحددوا زمن يحدد لعوده التيار
الكهربائي في اوديسا وكان يمكن ان يعود
التيار في خلال ايام لكن الضربه كانت وهي
سيستعيدون التيار في فتره قد يعني تستمر
لمده اسبوع او اسبوعين هذا الحال هو في
عوده
وجميع المدن الاوكرانيه سواء كان في وسط
وشمال البلاد وفي شقه البلاد وايضا حتى في
غرب البلاد المواطنين الاوكرانيين يعانون
انا ساقول لكم الصوره سترون معي نحن الان
امام همم منزل اسره السيده
نرى بام اعيننا كيف يع الاوكرانيون يعني
في الوقت الكهرباء موجوده طبعا عاده
التيار الكهربائي قبل ساعه واحده دراسه
سنه
يعني انا احيي سيد اقسانه واشكره عن همم
انها يعني همم دعتنا الى منزلها همم
كيف يعيشون الان في الوقت الراهن همم
كم من الوقت يتم همم قطع التيار الكهربائي
خلال اليوم
بس ما تتجوز نصاب بشكر القران
هي تقول انه اذا كان مع بدايه الازمع وما
مع بدايه الاستهدافات لمنشات الطاقه كان
يتم قطع التيار الكهربائي
مره او مرتين في اليوم ولكن الان يتم قطع
الكهرباء لفترات طويله جدا واكثر من مره
في اليوم على على سبيل المثال اليوم كان
لدينا تيار كهربائي لمده ساعتين فقط في
خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه
البطاريه
[موسيقى]
سبايدر مان
عندما يقطع التيار تتوقف هذه تسمى
بالبطاريات وهي التدفئه طبعا تتوقف تماما
لا يكون هنالك في المنزل قالت ان لديها
مقياس لدرجه الحراره في المنزل والان درجه
الحراره في المنزل لانه تيار هذا قبل قليل
الان درجه الحراره هي 14 درجه داخل الشقه
هنا
خلاص بتاع جورج
شمس
ااا ايضا يعني تقول انه
نقوم برفع الستائر قليلا حتى يكون هنالك
مزيد من في المنزل ايضا قالت ان لدي ابنه
هي تدرس في الصف الاول ودائما يكون هنالك
دروس يجب ان تقوم بها في المنزل لذلك اول
التيار الكهربائي يكون مقطوع لفترات طويله
خلال اليوم وهي تنام في وقت مبكر لذلك انا
استخدم هذه
الاضاءه وهي تقوم بشحنها خلال همم تواجد
التيار الكهربائي وبعد ذلك تستخدمها ل-
همم للطفله يعني للدراسه ولي مراجعه
الدروس
هذه الطفله وهي تلون او غدا اسال عن
الدراسه يعني هذه الطفله وغيرها من
الاطفال همم يعني التعليم كيف يحصل الان
في اوكرانيا ان كان عن بعد اون لاين همم
والكهرباء تنقطع بشكل كبير كيف يتم تدبر
هذا
يعني اوجه السؤال لاكسانا ساسال سنه
روك
الى المدرسه
[موسيقى]
يعني ايضا هنالك بعض الوسائل التي
يستخدمها الاوكرانيون همم
لاجتياز هذه الازمهم يعني همم
في اوقات طويله جدا لا تكون لا يوجد تيار
لذلك لا استطيع ان اطبخ لي عائلتي لذلك
همم
انبوبه غاز صغير جدا نستخدمه عندما تكون
همم يكون التيار مقطوع وعليه نقوم بعمليات
الطبخ همم في المنزل ايضا هنالك وسيله
اخرى يستخدمونها هم يقومون بتعبئه بعض
القوارير بالمياه الدافئه والمياه الساخنه
ويضعونها في الفراش لان التيار الكهربائي
ايضا يكون مقطوعه احيانا في الليل حتى
الصباح يضعونها معه في الفراش لتدفئاتهم
ايضا يستخدمون مثل هذا همم الترمس هم
يقومون بتعبيته بالمياه الساخنه
لاستخدامها همم اخرى اخرى
يعني وشكر ايضا للسيده التي استقبلت
واستقبلت الكاميرا العربيه لننقل هذه
المعاناه شكرا جزيلا لكما